you know what bothered me the most about
January 6th
the merch
[Laughter]
a merch at the revolution
Abraham Lincoln didn't sell top hats
did we just lose World War III to a bar
league softball team what is
who are these absentee dads on Instagram
live spending their child support money
on
on merch you're smashing up the capital
so that your Fired Guy can keep his job
can you imagine the slave mentality of
lifting a finger for the You're
Fired Guy i-4-1 cannot
[Laughter]
on real unnecessary white trash block
party that one right there
how many golf pros you think storm the
capital
pro golfers just guys running driving
ranges somewhere